BUCKLE UP.
TIME FOR OUR BREAKS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
TONIGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED THAT PERSON ALLEGEDLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MAIL BOMB
SCARE IS IN CUSTODY.
>> I AM PLEASED TO INFORM YOU
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT APPREHENDED
THE SUSPECT AND TAKE HIM INTO
CUSTODY.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> AN INCREDIBLE JOB BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WE CARRIED OUT A FAR-REACHING
FEDERAL, STATE AND LOCAL
INVESTIGATION.
TO FIND THE PERSON OR PERSONS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE EVENTS.
THESE TERRORIZING ACT ARE
DESPICABLE AND HAVE NO PLACE IN
OUR COUNTRY.
I HAVE INSTRUCTED AUTHORITIES TO
SPARE NO EXPENSE TO FIND THOSE
RESPONSIBLE AND THING THEM TO
SWIFT AND CERTAIN JUSTICE.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> WE MUST NEVER ALLOW POLITICAL
VIOLENCE TO TAKE ROOT IN
AMERICA.
WE CAN'T LET IT HAPPEN.
I AM COMMITTED TO DOING
EVERYTHING IN MY POWER AS
PRESIDENT TO STOP IT AND TO STOP
IT NOW.
>> Sean: MENN.
OO AMEN.
FEDERAL OFFICIALS THANKS TO
THEIR HARD WORK AND
DETERMINATION, HERE'S WHAT WE
KNOW ABOUT THE SUBJECT.
-- SUSPECT.
THE NAME IS CESAR SAYOC.
A MIDDLED AGE RESIDENT WITH A
LONG TRACK RECORD WITH THEFT,
DRUG CHARGES AND MADE A BOMB
THREAT BACK THIS 2002.
AND SAYAC HAS DOZENS OF FELONY
AND MISDEMEANOR CHARGES.
HE FILED FOR BANKRUPTCY IN 2012
WHEN HE WAS LIVING WITH HIS
MOTHER.
HIS VAN WAS COVERED WITH MANY
BIZARRE BUMPER STICKERS AND HIS
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS WERE
EQUALLY ODD.
THIS IS A PICTURE OF AN
IRRATIONAL MAN WHO IS DEEPLY
TROUBLED.
THE PRESIDENT SAID WE WANT
ANYBODY RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
BOMB SCARE TO BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE.
IF SAYAC IS FOUND GUILTY HE
SHOULD GO TO PRISON FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME.
SAYACOC IS FOUND GUILTY HE
SHOULD GO TO PRISON FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME.
SAYOC.
WE SOLVE OUR PROBLEMS AT THE
BALLOT BOX.
WHAT WE HAVE WITNESSED IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND THE LEFT
THE MEDIA RUSHED TO JUDGMENT AND
PUT FACTS LAST.
THEY DID ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO LINK PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND ANYONE WHO SUPPORTS HIM TO
THIS ACT OF TERRORISM.
EVEN THE GRAPHICS ON FAKE NEWS
CNN BLAMING TRUMP CALLING THE
BOMB VICTIMS TRUMPS TARGETS.
IT WAS WORSE ON-AIR.
THIS SHOULD MAKE YOUR HEART
SINK.
>> THE LIST OF TARGETS WAS OUT
OF TRUMP'S PLAYBOOK.
THE BOMBER'S ENEMIES WERE HIS
ENEMIES.
HE SAID AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
>> EVERYBODY SHOULD STOP
PRETENDING THAT TRUMP DOESN'T
KNOW WHAT HE IS DOING.
THAT WHEN HE SAYS THESE THINGS
HE KNOWS WHAT HE IS TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE.
>> DONALD TRUMP FAILS THE
COUNTRY.
HE FAILS AND DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS AND ALL AMERICANS IN
BETWEEN.
>> HE REFUSED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
WHAT ROLE HIS RHETORIC PLAYED IN
CULTIVATING THE CURRENT
POLITICAL CLIMATE.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS AN
OBLIGATION TO STOP PICKING ON
THE REPORTERS.
>> THE PRESIDENT CREATED A
CULTURE OF COMFORT FOR ACTUAL
VIOLENCE.
HE SPENDS MOST OF HIS TIME AT
HIS RALLIES THROWING VERBAL
BOMBS AT ALL OF THE PEOPLE THAT
RECEIVE THESE BOMBS IN THE MAIL.
>> Sean: AND ONE FAKE NEWS CNN
ANALYST BLAMED YOURS TRULY FOR
THE BOMB SCARE RELATING TO
ROBERT MUELLER.
-- ROBERT DE NIRO.
>> WHY ROBERT DE NIRO?
HE HASN'T CRITICIZED THE
PRESIDENT.
WHAT SEAN HANNITY SAID HAD A
DIRECT LINK.
>> MAY HAVE.
WE DON'T KNOW THE MOTIVE.
YOU SEE A PATTERN BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTACKS ON TWITTER
AND ECHOED BY FOX NEWS.
DE NIRO IS NOT LIKE THE OTHERS.
WHY ROBERT DE NIRO?
OCTOBER 15th SEAN HANNITY
BLASTED ROBERT DE NIRO WHERE HE
SAID THE TRUMP ALLIES MADE A
DEAL WITH THE DEVIL.
ROBERT DE NIRO CALLING US DEVIL
WORSHIPPERS.
IT'S PLAYING THE VICTIM CARD.
>> Sean: HE IS LYING AND
IGNORANT AND IRRESPONSIBLE.
HE IS THE WALKING EMBODEMENT OF
WHY SO MANY AMERICANS JUST DON'T
TRUST THE MEDIA.
WHY THEY CHANT "CNN SUCKS."
MAYBE HE SHOULD WATCH "HANNITY"
OR LISTEN TO MY RADIO SHOW.
HE WOULD SEE HOW I CALL ON
POLITICAL VILIFICATION IN THIS
COUNTRY TO STOP.
ESPECIALLY THE CONFRONTATIONS.
I DEPLORE IT.
HE WOULD KNOW HOW MUCH I VALUE
LAW AND ALREADY AND THE SAFETY
OF EVERYONE INCLUDING PEOPLE I
DISAGREE WITH PASSIONATELY.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN PRESIDENT
OBAMA'S SECURITY WAS THREATENED
IN 2014, I SPOKE OUT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN HOW WE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR PRESIDENT EVEN
THOUGH I HAD STRONG
DISAGREEMENTS WITH HIM.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE HAVE THE FENCE JUMPER WHO
MADE IT PAST THE STAIRS GOING UP
TO THE RESIDENCE.
WE HAVE THE SECOND INCIDENT IN
2011, 6 SHOTS FIRED AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
TOOK THEM 4 DAYS TO DETERMINE IT
WAS NOTHING TO WITH THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THEN A GUY WITH A GUN GOT ON AN
ELEVATOR WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
ISIS, OUR ENEMIES ARE WATCHING
US.
WE HAVE TO PROTECT OUR
PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: EVERY ELECTED OFFICIAL
DESERVES SECURITY.
EVERYONE DESERVES SAFETY.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO ANYONE WHO
WAS EVER THREATENED OR HARMED.
I KNOW FIRSTHAND HOW IT FEELS I
HAVE BEEN THROUGH WHITE POWDER
MAILED TO ME SAYING IT WAS A
ANTHRAX.
I HAD TREATS TO MYSELF AND MY
FAMILY.
LUNATICS HAVE NO POLITICAL
BOUNDARIES.
TO SUGGEST THAT CRITICISM IS THE
MOTIVATING FORCE BEHIND ONE
FRINGE VIOLENT INDIVIDUAL IS
LAZY, JOHN, AND JUST NOTHING BUT
A CHEAP ATTEMPT TO CAPITALIZE
OFF A SERIES INCIDENT.
YOU SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
YOURSELF.
I NEVER BLAMED BERNIE SANDERS
BECAUSE ONE OF HIS LOYAL
SUPPORTERS SHOT REPUBLICAN
LAWMAKERS AND NEARLY KILLED
STEVE SCALISE ON A BASEBALL
FIELD.
I SAID THE OPPOSITE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I AM NOT BLAMING BERNIE
SANDERS.
>> OF COURSE.
>> THIS WAS ONE NUT.
REMEMBER THE BERNIE SANDERS
REPORTER THAT TARGETED
REPUBLICANS AT BASEBALL PRACTICE
LEAVING CONGRESSMAN STEVE
SCALISE FIGHTING FOR HIS LIFE?
WAS THE MEDIA BLAMING DEMOCRATS
FOR THAT?
NO.
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE.
I DON'T BLAME BERNIE SANDERS
EITHER.
IT WOULD BE IRRESPONSIBLE TO TIE
HIM TO WHAT ONE NUT SUPPORTER
DOES.
I SAID MANY TIMES THERE ARE
DERANGED INDIVIDUALS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE ISLEWOOD.
THEY AND THEY ALONE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR EVIL
ACTIONS.
THIS BRINGS US TO OUR NEXT
POINT.
ALL OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
CONDEMNS DESTRUCTIVE RHETORIC
FROM ONLY THE RIGHT.
REFLECT INWARD FIRST.
IN THE PAST 24 HOURS THE
ANTI-TRUMP FROM THE DESTROY
TRUMP MEDIA IS DESPICABLE.
WE HAVE THE TAPE.
>> WHEN YOU KEEP STIRRING THAT
POT AND YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES, PEOPLE
LISTEN TO HIM.
HE IS NOT ON A TALK SHOW.
THIS IS WHIPPING UP PEOPLE.
YOU WILL SEE PEOPLE RESPOND.
>> HE WAS ELECTED TO BE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES,
NOT A MENTAL PATIENT.
>> THIS IS ESCALATING.
IT WILL PROBABLY GET WORSE IF HE
DOESN'T CHANGE HIS TONE.
>> Sean: MAYBE THEY SHOULD
LECTURE MAXINE WATERS.
FOLLOW THEM TO STORES AND GAS
STATIONS.
THE HATRED OF ALL THINGS TRUMP
HAVE BEEN BOILING OVER SINCE THE
DAY HE AND MELANIA CAME DOWN THE
ESCALATOR.
HERE IS A SMALL SAMPLING OF THE
INSANITY.
>> IF YOU SEE ANYBODY FROM THAT
PARTY IN A DEPARTMENT STORE OR A
GAS STATION, YOU GET UP AND YOU
TELL THEM THEY ARE NOT WELCOMED.
>> YOU CANNOT BE CIVIL WITH A
POLITICAL PARTY THAT WANTS TO
DESTROY WHAT YOU STAND FOR.
WHAT YOU CARE ABOUT.
>> WHEN THEY GO LOW, WE GO HIGH.
NO, NO.
WHEN THEY GO LOW, WE KICK THEM.
>> HOW DARE HIM SAY THE THINGS
HE DOES?
I WANT TO PUNCH HIM IN THE FACE.
>> RIGHT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> YES, I HAVE THOUGHT AN AWFUL
LOT OF BLOWING UP THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME AN
ACTOR ASSASSINATED A PRESIDENT?
IT'S BEEN A WHILE.
>> MAYBE IT'S TIME.
>> JOURNALISTS WHO TRY TO COME
WHAT THE TRUTH IS.
>> I WANT TO READ THE DEFINITION
OF TREASON.
>> WE SEE A SHADOW GOVERNMENT
COME OUT TO SAY WE CAN'T SIDE
WITH THE GOVERNMENT.
>> THE GUY WANTS TO KILL US.
>> THERE WAS A SIGN HUNG UP
OUTSIDE OF THE WHITE HOUSE, IF
YOU ARE NOT WHITE, YOU ARE NOT
WELCOME.
>> Sean: IT WAS RHETORIC LIKE
THAT, IT'S ODD THEY BLAME DONALD
TRUMP FOR THE ACTIONS OF A
LUNATIC.
SINCE DERANGED FAR LEFT
INDIVIDUALS WE HAVE BEEN
WATCHING FOR WEEKS THREATENING
REPUBLICANS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
JUST IN RECENT WEEKS.
WE HAVE BEEN WARNING YOU AND
RAND PAUL WARNED YOU:
SOMETHING HORRIBLE WILL HAPPEN.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF IT'S LEFT
OR RIGHT.
THE LEFT SILENCED HAD IT'S THEIR
SIDE.
IT'S DEAFENING AND WORSE.
SOME ELECTED OFFICIALS SENT OUT
MARCHING ORDERS TO HARASS
CABINET OFFICIALS AND
CANDIDATES.
WHITE POWERED MAILED TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE AND THE FBI
DIRECTOR WRAY AND HASKELL.
THE PRESIDENT'S SON WAS TARGETED
WITH A SUSPICIOUS PACKAGE.
A TRUMP BUMPER STICKER WAS SET
ON FIRE.
2 REPUBLICANS CANDIDATES IN
MINNESOTA WHO WERE PUNCHED.
ONE A WOMAN AND ANOTHER MAN WITH
SEVERE INJURIES.
6 WEEKS, BAD CONCUSSION.
REPUBLICAN CAMPAIGN MANAGER IN
NEVADA WAS ASSAULTED.
DOZENS MORE INCIDENT OF
VANDALISM AND TOP REPUBLICANS
STALKED IN AIRPORTS AND RUN OUT
OF RESTAURANTS.
WE HAVE SHOWN YOU THIS
VIDEOTAPE.
WHILE WE CONDEMN ACT OF VIOLENCE
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE, WHEN
SOMETHING HAPPENS TO A
CONSERVATIVE, DEMOCRATS ARE
MISSING IN ACTION AND SILENT.
WE WILL HAVE MORE.
FIRST MORE BIG NEWS ON THE
LOOMING CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THE MIGRANT CARAVAN IS MOVING
NORTH.
DEFENSE SECOND MATTIS APPROVED A
REQUEST TO SEND MORE TROOPS TO
THE BORDER TO BOLSTER THE
ACTIONS OF THE BORDER PATROL.
THE PRESIDENT SAID TURN BACK.